can you explain how a director can
micromanage an actor in their
performance yes by talking too much
that's the quick answer to that there
are uh
directors who
uh
you know want to they want to delve into
the inner life a lot they want to talk
talk talk they want to they want to um
uh
front load
that's one that's the thing that i think
is the most dangerous is when you know
the director has a very
uh
idea that he or she is very excited
about and they want to front load the
actor with it before
before they um before they even do
anything
and they over talk it's the simplest
thing is over talking
i finally boiled it down to telling
directors listen more than you talk and
be
percentage about that hear your own
voice less than 50 of the time when
you're talking to actors
listen to them more than you talk to
them
and uh and and that's a big big thing
that
that um
that actors complain about is directors
that over talk but they still don't
understand what they what the director
wants
that's that's just so easy to happen and
that's so so
very
simply um
unders
circumvented if the director knows
understands the tool of emotional event
because that's much uh takes much less
time to talk about and then
if you if you can say to the actors
wait this is this is not a
this is this is not a family you know
nice people being nice this is an
argument
and uh and then let the actors get there
however they get there instead of sort
of micro well now you have to you have
to get mad and then you have to be
disappointed and then you have to get
mad back and now you have to and that's
micromanaging is is is
sort of
giving the result for each
each emotional turning point that you
want
that's another way to to micromanage
rather than allowing each actor to have
a through line through on an objective
something they want or need from the
other actor
and an obstacle of course very useful
and um
and then let them let let's say ins and
outs of how they win the argument or
lose the argument let that happen in a
moment
you know if they both want something
from each other
what if they're not getting the result
they want
i encourage
directors to want
a different result than sometimes they
think they do because sometimes they've
gotten married in their minds to a
certain
uh
that they think their eyebrows are
supposed to rise at a certain point or
they're supposed to be a certain line
reading at a certain point
or they're supposed to be a certain
pitch of anger or
uh at a certain point and and i try to
get them this is with script analysis i
try to get them to use their script
analysis to get to a different thing to
want
to get to the uh the emotional event
that they want
uh because if they want if they want
those
those uh particular
surface things
i can't tell them how to get it i really
can't so i spend a lot of my time trying
to get them to want something else
so maybe the director doesn't know what
they want
that's how it feels to the actor
that that if the if the director keeps
saying well raise your eyebrow just a
little bit more then the director think
they don't know what they want
they think they want that but they don't
really know what they want
and and that is about the you know
what the scene is about is it
is it a
is it about uh oh survival
is a scene about survival only one will
survive say
is the scene about
uh
loss of purpose
is the scene about uh existing a
confession
that gets accepted
or or not
you know those are the things
and it it it's it's not that easy for
for uh directors to get to that uh
they have to do some script analysis
they have to look underneath the surface
of the script and underneath the surface
of the instructions that the stage
directions give them
uh to to find it and it takes practice
and and it's useful not just for talking
to actors but for talking to anybody for
talking to your cinematographer or
talking to uh you know production
designer or producers or uh financial
people it's useful for
uh for anything so it's a different way
of looking
at what the scene is supposed to be
what if someone's trying to talk to
someone more because they feel like
they're not
getting the truth of what's going on or
there's a disconnect there's something
that's not being said
wait can you say more about that sure so
if if the director is talking too much
uh maybe they're doing it as a way to
fill in the lines of something that's
not being said or
something that's not coming to the
surface so they're using it as a tool
their own tool well
actors do the best they can to
figure out what what the
director wants
um
so if the director is over talking now
they'll listen for little clues to give
them something to to try on the next
take
what is the language of permission
it's a way of
in engaging the
the actors
with the process
uh
it can be as simple as saying
um i had this idea
that this could be that this scene could
have higher stakes do you want to try
that
instead of saying get angrier
okay you know uh and
uh
so it's that's the language an example
of the language of permission
is uh offering
offering the actors
a way to away just you know giving them
giving them the opportunity to say no
and then if and then because it's good
to find out if an actor doesn't like
your direction
uh it's good to find out because then
you can say okay well i'm going to try
to make a case for this
let me tell you why i think this is
worth trying and it's it's very helpful
a key element of the language of
permission is that when you when if if
the actor has a different idea than
yours than the director's mind if i'm
the director that i am not if i discuss
it with the actor i'm not trying to
convince them that my idea is better
than theirs
but i'm trying to convince them that my
idea is worth trying
so it's being soft with people it's not
being abrupt
it's asking hey
you know judith could we try it maybe
this way instead of me dictating to you
like judith no i need you to do it this
way i'm i'm showing you respect
i'm being soft
it's partly but
i guess if i use myself as an example
when i'm directing i have a lot of
energy so i don't i wouldn't say that
i'm soft i'm very energetic
so it's not an energy level
it's uh
it's
it's checking in
it's checking in i wouldn't say it's an
energy level
because i my energy is very high and
when i really want something
i'll say wait okay i maybe i haven't
explained this yet but there's something
that i want that we're not getting to
and let and tell me what you think i'm
saying
you know to get feedback tell me what
you and you see how a conversation like
that has to be private
sure but you're checking in instead of
checking in and giving orders and so
even if the energy is intense there's
still a mutual respect
i think so yeah yeah they're
collaborators
they're collaborators they're artists
and they are
people
and
and uh
and they're smart
so why wouldn't you use all of the
brains
on the set